what does it mean to win a grand chest
or title that encompasses classical
rapid and blitz I hope I'd be able to
tell you after the tournament yes this
is a very tough challenge of course and
Magnus for instance is probably the best
player at all for March getting to the
final and winning German is something
that you you kind of tell to yourself
that this was a good year this was a
great year since you don't need to beat
one player in three time control you
just need to beat them in total by
points even if you're lost in one time
control I feel when the other tool that
you might still beat them I think it
makes a lot of sense that since the tour
itself it's it's comprised of both
classical rapid and weights that finals
should reflect that and I think whoever
wins it will be worthy winner because
they showed that they can do well in any
format this year in particular you see
you have usual people who get to the
final like Hikaru
I mean Fabi was there a year ago and
this year they were not even close so it
shows that
the field is getting more competitive
very big challenge it takes skill to
adapt and to you know change formats in
between games but yeah I hope I'll be
ready to pounce I think it's interesting
that you have to make adjustments
despite the fact you that you don't like
the blades are rapid you can't just sit
there and say I'm a classical player you
have to work your way out there and just
sacrifice some things to make it to
determine what significance would it be
to you personally to win the grand chest
war title for 2019
of course Grantchester title is mark
you've done you've done quite well
amongst the elite everyone's been
playing here they see also so they do it
really mean a lot
you make this tournament very special
every tournament for us elite players
yes yeah I always play badly London so
it's already kind of a thing that I feel
oh I'm just coming here for a holiday or
and it's a really bad feeling
so really won't change it so I'll try it
this time to to take a different
approach they would would mean a lot to
me